I love Arnold impersonations because you
know half of the time they're cartoony
and half the time they're good but no
matter which one is everybody we'll just
do the random vocalizations that I've
never actually heard him do that much
just the I love Wow like the Arnold
stroke noises we see Hercules in New
York like a hundred percent
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
did you understand what hey guys Greg
Albee here Jonel I mean whoever we're in
the same shoe don't worry yesterday as
I'm getting back from the gym all sweaty
and professional for the camera
definitely haha we are the laziest form
of entertainment am i right right go
cover myself in mud I'll be right back
we're gonna watch the honest trailers
for 1987's predator a movie I recently
revisited and a movie I should revisit
before we see the new film on Thursday
which by the way is getting tremendous
all the reviews yeah reviews are
definitely happening to him looks like
my theories about that movie having a
lot of humor they were hiding very true
[Music]
for the Michael Bay of the eighties it
was the best hand shake it all of human
history watch that men to the stage
still do that yeah that's one was into
American jungle where no one can hear
you sweat see serious letting men for
sport and that something would have been
an awesome mystery if they didn't show a
spaceship in the first scene it's an
alien besides their alien I saw the ship
[Music]
okay fine I'll do what YouTube comments
do movie starts at one minute twenty
nine seconds the watch of Native
American Blaine the jacked up macho
redneck back in Dillon the jacked up
macho white guys walkins the
screenwriter they wanted on separate
puncher and their leader Dutch objective
bass and horse chuffing Kevin
McCallister
[Applause]
whoa you just build hello Charlie
Garrett John called Ben David stupid
monster costume that would have a way
better happened but once he got fired
they went up against the real ultimate
enemy the predator a perfect mix of
awesome creature design acid and mesh
bodysuit Bryce laughs I favor that who
uses advanced technology to hunt the
equivalent of fish in a barrel
yes he's less cool when you realize he's
like those yuppies who shoot two rats
with a sniper rifle oh yeah predator
revisit the predator that's never been
improved on in its secret most ly well
because in an action forum of this good
with so many iconic lies
[Music]
and such an iconic movie monster you'll
barely even notice that half the bill is
just quietly looking at trees starring
cool the future Governor of California
the future governor of Minnesota
watch your candidate for governor of
Kentucky why this is getting weird
maybe you've got a stoop going to
moisturize
that's the OS a man 3 and I gotta get a
job my stall Mike back looks like a 90s
sitcom never utters
Oh Arnold was the only one who did it
she was they just took an actual some
part of the movie but everyone else did
I may not as expendable ut-oh there's
nothing sadder than an empty pizza box
10-4 good buddy
good job artists trailers I loved Emmy
nominated writers man you know I thought
about what they're talking about with
the opening with the alien coming in
well the the thing is I think it would
have been very jarring if suddenly there
was like an alien it's like it could
have worked but I don't know if at that
time it would have worked and I don't
know how like test screenings or
whatever would have worked back then but
I almost wonder if that was something
that they added to make it a little more
cohesive or something yeah it's like you
have this T's opening image and then
after a while you completely forget
about the front I think I think it is
you feel like you're just watching like
a guerrilla army just
skinning these people and stuff like
that's what they play it like they play
it like it's an actual war zone movie
and then halfway through it turns into
like a sci-fi slasher movie I think
that's neat but I feel like at that time
would have been very jarring and it kind
of makes me think of vessel dawn where
that's very jarring but I think for that
time that worked at this I don't know
1980s I think I would have been people
don't like surprises in the eighties you
still don't know what it was though yeah
yeah yeah all I saw was an eight on a
spaceship and then something launched
from it which is a really cool shot I
think it's a good opening shot yeah yeah
it builds the intrigue definitely I
never put much mind to the idea that so
much in the movies is people staring
into trees but it's an incredibly
pertinent point you know that tension
yeah I need those reactions
stuff like that I just yeah it's those
things that you don't think about until
they're removed from the overall context
I actually really appreciated when they
had the Jesse Ventura line when he says
the F word for gay people
Jordan I showed this movie did my
girlfriend recently and she had never
watched this movie before
but things I was saying to her was like
this movie holds it really well when the
way they put it out that line I I forgot
about that line and she was like whoa to
that slip at the same time though you
know when you're thinking about like
these these kind of rescue team
mercenary like men nimac it still fits
with the characters does it use that
line yeah yeah yeah yeah well as an
action horror movie I mean all the
production values and all those all the
pulp and stuff yeah for sure
yeah they're they're they're gonna be
some off-color whoo lines here I feel
like any time you get like meatheads
together and it's before 2000 it was
funny about the Native American guy
plays Billy his stand-up routine yeah
man secretly a great comic gonna cut out
all his jokes Easter Egg shame black
took all the jokes I was going down to
my girlfriend said to her geez you got a
big [ __ ] juice you got a big [ __ ] you
said why did you say that twice and I
said I didn't
see
[Music]
if you go to his IMDB he plays the
character of Billy you got Native
American guy fact that 48 hours plays
Billy barehand Castle and mcCormick
sheriff Billy Blackstone predator Billy
Billy lone bear Billy he's like that
Hispanic actor who always plays Hector
yeah I think their best bit here the
best comedy bit is definitely the
comparisons the home alone that was you
remember bond oh yeah you know when I
was watching this movie back I was kind
of wondering how Arnold was he got so
much done in that day so many elaborate
things that would have been so
time-consuming if you had a crew he's
like making so much noise he's no is he
not found by the predator and all that
time it's like building these crazy
elaborate traps and weapons arrow that
explodes yeah I wanted to look that up
because I've heard that that is really
stupid mud would not cover up yeah it's
exact hold I don't know like I can't
imagine it would work for very long if
it worked at all because eventually your
body heat would temper tries it at the
very least and then it can see you again
why is maca always shaving in this movie
is a weird tic I feel like that's a
badass trope it's just like one guys
always shave well I love about the guy
Mac is he's he I think he does a really
good job the thing is he also seems like
he's in a different movie i he seemed
like the the one actor who who probably
wouldn't method on the table like when
he's going after the predator and he's
act I'm happy so fun I'm super happy so
far
[Music]
you're more committed than everyone else
in this movie aren't you yeah you gotta
you gotta appreciate always appreciated
that guy among the cast what do you ever
you have one guys clearly taking it more
serious than everybody I'm like hey at
least nobody can accuse you of not doing
your job that end credits scene is that
was my exact common when I watched it
back it's a sitcom why is it a sitcom
yeah what I love though is everything
blacks mean everyone does the sitcom
part except Arnold Arnold they took an
actual moment from the scene and then
just threw him in there at the end maybe
it hitched him the idea he's like I'm
not doing alright guys well thanks arms
trailers we got our tickets for predator
on IMAX money well spent you could
follow us on here it's by subscribing
and clicking bells and check us out on
patreon where we got TV show reactions
and q and A's good died right